sorry i've not had an opportunity to get
in my emails
okay longer than short of it she'll need
to
it's now live for you chair thank you
good afternoon everyone welcome to the
uh meeting the north east arborsha
district council cabinet
it's uh 4 30 on the 10th of september
um we'll get straight on with the agenda
first we have apologies for absence do
we have any
uh non-procedure although councillor
hutchinson would have liked to attend
for the item
on uh the overview and security work
program was unable to attend today
no problem okay we'll note council
hutchinson's
um apologies for that then um
next item is declarations of interest i
think the only to declare is
probably for myself and councillor cupid
for the
area housing offices paper paper seven
on the agenda
we were obviously members of the board
at wrigle at the time at which they
initiated that that proposal and that
consultation
um so i think it's best that we don't
participate or vote
uh in that discussion um because we've
already approved it from a board
perspective um okay any other
declarations of interest from anyone
non-received chair charlotte uh just to
clarify on that chair
do we need to leave the meeting for that
item or are we remaining in the meeting
might be a question sir clara could you
advise
um if you were physically in the meeting
you would be asked to leave the chamber
so i don't know nikki if we can arrange
for
cancerdale and councillor cupid to leave
and then return for the next item
the second problem so that's council
dale and councillor cupid leaving for
which item of business approaches
item 7 which is the area housing office
consultation
at that point i'll pop you into the
waiting room brilliant thank you nikki
okay uh
okay so that confirms decoration of
interest and the next item is minute to
the last meeting
held on the 20th of august
i'll go through them page by page please
shout out if there's any
issues of accuracy anything on
page one page two
page three page four
or page five if not are we happy to
approve as a true and accurate record
yeah can you raise hands thank you
brilliant
okay and then we come to the proposed
overview
and scrutiny work programmes um
is it best to hand over to you sue to
talk through that paper
it is thank you very much um yes uh
thank you this is the usual work
programme report that comes to cabinet
every year
um you'll be aware that uh scrutiny is
required to keep cabinet informed of the
work that they're proposing to do during
the year
there's nothing unusual on it it's uh
two strands of work
chiefly which is the review reports
which are set out in 1.5
of the report and then the usual
overview
of policies and services um we try to
concentrate on the key uh policies
strategies because obviously there's so
many we couldn't look at them all
and also look at services perhaps where
there's an issue or
you know we've been asked to do some uh
review work
um i'd just say it's a live document
it's not set in stone
uh it can be changed we try to leave
some capacity
for urgent or emerging issues if we need
to
look at items um so there's nothing
further i need to say chair unless you
have any questions on
on what's on there okay thanks sue
yeah it looks like a busy program of
work for the next
uh for the next year uh and obviously
some interesting topics that
i can see the the the committees are
looking at there
are there any other comments or
questions from from members
anything anyone wants to make clear no
okay thank you for that
are we all happy to uh we're being asked
to
support the attached overview and
scrutiny work programs for
2021 i'll move that is there a second
cancel parking and all those in favor
i mean that's carried thank you and then
we come to the
uh the reviews of or one of the reviews
of
last year's scrutiny reviews which is
the residential parking
review and i'll hand over to councillor
kevin tate
to talk us through this one
hi thank you alex and so last year we
met six times
and we were given the instruction by
council
and considered provision for parking
within the district
so during those six meetings we met and
looked through various uh policies that
we hold
and various stakeholders spoke to rick
knolls
and spoke to four parish councils as
well we
had clay cross dropping killer marsh
and the overview of parking within the
district was that there was
many many different problems within
different areas
not one general problem within them all
and
so through that we came up with the
recommendations uh
firstly
we uh considered like dog fouling
and potholes for example and
for a portal to be on the website
so that people could report they could
report parking
we thought this was a good idea because
it was a very
easy thing to do we considered and it
would be quite uh
give us an overview within the district
where our key areas are that needs to
target
the other option other the ones where
to use grass creek this is like a
mesh so like it can be used on verges
because uh when we spoke to
various people what was happening was
people were parking on the verges anyway
and to avoid tarmacking over them
this seemed like an alternative to that
and we also looked at planning
uh with new new applications
the the minimum parking spaces you can
put in your application 1.5 so if you
put an application in for planning
or a development you only have to
allocate 1.5 spaces
for dwelling and we looked at that and
we considered that
not a lot of people have one and a half
cars
so what was happening is it was
impacting on the streets
and affecting things like refuse
collection people double parking
so we look to increase that to two as a
minimum
and also looked at garage spaces because
garage is no longer really used
or not as much as they were and they
were
generally quite small because cars were
a lot smaller back
then so what's happening is that they're
getting
left for storage those kinds of things
so we looked at
whether these could be used if they're
not they're currently not in use
whether it's to be used as a parking
area just to take the
overflow from the streets and
and we looked at increasing the budget
for enforcement when we spoke to
killer marsh i think it was and
there the main thing they were saying
was enforcement because their people
know that it's not gonna uh bad parking
is not gonna be enforced
and they were quite happy people were
happy to arc and double yellows or
double park
knowing that there was no repercussions
for them because
there was no enforcement so those are
the
recommendations i'm happy to take any
questions
you very much kevin uh yeah i think this
is a really useful timely review
uh we i think the recommendations are
really
uh really useful the very simple things
that i think well
certainly some of them are very simple
things that we could do quite quickly
hopefully
uh that would um that would deliver some
changes so the
the website facility i'm sure is
something that we could
certainly look further at and um i think
the
uh the issue of new developments in
particular i know you highlighted that
and refused wagons
charlotte and i were actually out with
some of the street scene teams today and
even they brought up the fact that
often new developments have very narrow
streets and very rarely do they have
sufficient parking so it is a real
problem
um you know getting up and down there so
i think that would be
certainly something that we should um
very carefully consider and try and
introduce if it's all possible
um the thing around the recommendation
around review of garage sites i know
that
asset management group is already
looking at some of those so i think
council parking should be able to update
on that and then the issue around
enforcement and grassy i think we just
need to look very carefully at in terms
of the budget and whether we can
whether we can do that but i think if
there is possibility of doing it and
supporting or buying in some additional
parking enforcement from the county in
particular
that would be very very very good and i
think well received by
a lot of residents who are experiencing
problems so thank you very much for
uh your team and all the review uh and
and steve airman as well for the for the
work on this because it's a very useful
review
and hopefully we can take forward quite
a few if not all of those
recommendations
i'll bring council parking in next
uh thank you chair um yeah i'd like to
echo your comments to be honest i'm
really really happy with these uh with
these five
recommendations and uh i think it'll be
a matter of targeting
where uh where finance is available um
the the areas that uh that we've seen
most
uh most problems in but uh having read
through the report
i understand that um dcc are actually
the
authority for or for uh enforcing
the the parking regulations so i guess
we need to have a conversation about how
much it costs for
enforcement officers and and that as a
result of this report
but thank you very much for for bringing
this report it's uh
it's excellent and having had a not a
grass creek drive but a very similar
uh parking area in front in my uh in my
driveway for 12 years
uh i can certainly say that stuff works
so
so thank you very much um yeah that's me
my only question i think would be uh
that the uh would be about
um the minimum standard for car parking
spaces
not questioning the recommendation i
think that's correct
and i'm just question i would just
question whether you've had any feedback
from
developers about what impact that would
have on them
uh and indeed you had one on the panel
which was written
and i wondered whether reynolds gave you
any feedback
uh on that uh two parking space
um recommendation
okay i'll come back to you kevin for
that and then i'll bring mark
i in the simple answer is uh it didn't
really make much comment on the one and
a half spaces
i'm not sure we got rick killed in
before
or after sue my bill to um memory i'm
not sure if wrignel came in before we
looked at that or afterwards
so i i don't think they gave any comment
on it though now
okay i i can't recall any comment chair
on that from mcnult
yeah i think it's something that we'll
probably need
charlotte to take away in terms of
planning and whether it's whether it's
possible um and what document it needs
to be in that
that we create that sort of a protocol
so let's have a look and see what we can
do with that
um mark you want to go in
yeah uh thanks chair first of all uh
thank you council tate for the report
uh i'm going to agree and uh ask that we
accept all these recommendations
which will be as no surprise because i
worked on the
i was on communities when we uh when we
looked at these
uh when we looked at residential parking
um so
i'd be happy to accept all the
recommendations but in particular the
one that interests me most of all
is the second one which is uh the
increased civil enforcement
i think that's one that could make the
biggest difference um
and i wouldn't anticipate that it would
cost too much
when you look at civil enforcement yes
it's right the
uh county responsible for a fair amount
of civil enforcement
but uh the districts have done it before
too
and if i remember right the ones i've
seen around uh were private enforcement
officers
employed by the county and at the same
time they also did district work and
they had a velcro badge
uh they were a private company in
nottingham uh if i remember last uh
somebody else might know better here
but that's the last uh i remember so it
would be a
about not paying i think the
recommendations we spoke about we're not
paying the
uh the county for their work
but would be to use the same people that
they use and
use them for a set number of hours so
it's not about uh creating employment
it's not about taking anybody on it's
about using those same private services
and using them to uh enforce uh
parking in areas uh the district had a
an interest in
um i don't if uh i think that's what we
what we agreed at the end of
uh at the end of the study and i'm sure
that was uh
was in the recommendations so it was it
was to increase
uh put money towards a budget uh
to provide uh for enforcement in areas
that were a particular interest now we
know it's uh
it's counting they've got the
responsibility for it but there's areas
that we could look at too so i think
that's what it was about if that
that makes any sense yeah absolutely
yeah completely agree
um i'll bring carolyn in next
yeah and thank you council tate and i
think
all of us have car parking issues in
that is one of our
highest rates in terms of complaints
locally
uh quite frankly in eckinton it becomes
like the wild west
and what's disappointing to me is that
there's no enforcement i'm not seeing
any kind of
enforcement in there in our parish
for the years and so so personally i
would like
firstly this to be fed back in quite
strong terms to dcc in terms of
what how we can hold them to account for
this
but if there is any opportunity to
actually um increase enforcement
presence and i don't know the
um i don't know how you do that i don't
know what the what the rules regulations
are about
enforcement but i would certainly be
very happy
to support anything that would help set
the scene
because when you do actually have
somebody who does actually start
slapping tickets on cars
it doesn't take long for the message to
get across an area
that you can't park there any longer and
we've not had that for a long time
despite
repeated requests to the police and they
still haven't managed to do that
the only thing that i was going to
question as well is that um
on my walk around with whitmore and
there are lots of issues on some of the
estates
of our our own estates um and it was
about there's been a reluctance to allow
people to put
cars in their front gardens and i know
there's a cost
up i've never got my head around what
the cost to actually drop pavements and
get some
people residents actually once put cars
in their own drives but the moment
they prohibited uh putting them on i'm
just wondering if there's some clarity
on that
i seem to recall uh carolyn on that that
we
we agreed a um a sort of standard spec
and protocol for doing that
fairly recently it might have been
actually before you came onto cabinet it
was it was within the past few months
anyway so i think we've agreed
a process to allow people to do that and
what spec
in terms of driveway we would allow um
obviously for various reasons we want to
keep it to a specific
spec so that it doesn't it doesn't make
the the estates look untidy et cetera so
i think we've gone forward with that uh
and that's now in place
it was actually the cast council um
council dale that i was interested i i
think it was an asset that came with the
spec
um i've seen that i just i've never
never got anybody to give me a costs
oh okay to try and make see if we know
if it works and if it's
actively um publicized to
tenants who might or residents who might
want to do that
okay well we can maybe ask councillor
powell to uh to take that up
with with written then if that's
possible just to make sure that people
are aware of the costs
involved and what what they would need
to do um
to proceed to make sure it's well
advertised um
i'll hand over to councillor kenyon yeah
yes thank you yes thank you councillor
tate for the report
um it's very good i i agree with all the
recommendations there
and also the priority that someone said
about
enforcement first kilomarch neckington
definitely would uh benefit from that
but it's also the third one i'm
particularly interested in
the the grass creek it's it's a major
issue on some of our
narrower streets with with these grass
mergers
um but we're going to be proactive about
doing something about that what i would
hate to see is that recommendation
sitting there so somehow we need to i
don't know put out a call for
sites or call for problem areas again
and make sure that we actually
tackle them otherwise nothing will
happen and we'll be three years down the
road and
so so i'd like us to see a very strong
action to set up a
task force to progress that further
thanks thanks uh i was going to suggest
actually because i know from personal
experience with grass
grass crete uh trying to get it um
in a specific area in drum field
actually up the council partner with the
avenue
where they have a lot of grass
areas of the of the pavement sort of
thing where they get a heck of a lot of
uh vehicles going over and churning it
up uh i seem to recall the costs
for grass creek being quite prohibitive
uh it's not it's not apparently that or
the spec that
counts to use it's not that cheap but i
think the point that you make around a
task force or or a group to get going
i think i was going to add to the
recommendations that we look to set up
an early meeting with
the relevant people at dcc um to try and
work through how we would progress some
of these things and really
particularly around the enforcement and
the grass creek side of things how we
can
work with them to find solutions rather
than um
find barriers sort of thing um i think
councillor renick is next yeah now just
just added to that
uh council dale is that i don't have to
pursue um
this is an issue in the ridgeway and the
official line from the council was that
there's also flooding issues and they
were reluctant to do any of this
right okay okay well if oh
kevin i'll come back to you get a cancer
tape yeah the thing with the grass crate
was
it still allowed drainage yeah
so so you weren't creating a a wash-off
area straight into the drains it still
managed to
i don't know what the sub layers would
be
that's why that's why it's on the
recommendation because we were conscious
if we didn't just want to pave over
vast areas of land so that's why it's on
yeah good point uh i'll bring lee hicken
in i can see his
just a quick one uh we've done some work
recently around
uh grass creek versus traditional tarmac
and
there's not a lot of difference in terms
of cost i'll just throw that one in
there
between tarmac and something and grass
creating it the costs are about the same
but obviously you get the benefits for
grass creek that
is permeable it drains through uh you've
got the appearance of grass
et cetera et cetera et cetera yeah yeah
that's the point
okay well let's see if we can um
investigate that further and find if
there's another solution that might be
um slightly more economical than grass
creek but anyway we can we can explore
that
so um are there any further comments
before we move to the recommendations
no thank you for that well thank you
again uh councillor tate and all of the
uh committee council foster as well and
i was on this committee um
uh at the time of the the review so
thank you for all the work on that
um the office recommendations as i say
are uh that cabinet's asked to consider
the recommendations
uh and if i accepted ask officers to
provide a response in consultation with
the relevant portfolio holder
but i think this the recommendations
cross a few
portfolio holders i think it's in
particular council cupid and councillor
powell
and i think we also need to arrange an
early um
early meeting with dcc and the relevant
person at dcc to discuss
taking some of these further so if we
can task counselor cupid and council
powell to
spend a bit of time looking into some of
these and how we how we proceed with
them and get that meeting arranged with
dcc
um i'll happily assist if it needs to be
in getting the right person
um then we can hopefully try and make
some progress on them as soon as
possible
brilliant is everyone uh i'll move that
is there a seconder
yeah uh council foster and then all
those in favor
brilliant thank you very much okay
thanks kevin
uh you're very welcome today or all
depart if you'd like to
thank you for that um
and then the next item is the council
plan
targets performance update so this is my
paper
which i will move to shortly get my
ipad to work
with me um
so this is the first quarter
um so april to june of our
new council plan so this is the council
plan that we set as an administration
um it goes through the report goes
through in some detail
um the fact that covered is clearly
impacted
on some of our performance i think we
have to remember that this
is covering the period where
covid was most impacting as it was the
early period of lockdown
where a lot of the council resource had
to divert
to more uh sort of emergency services
and those sorts of things so
some of them um although they may seem
like
they they could have been progressed
further i think it's largely because
this period covers that initial period
of lockdown when
when we were moving council resources
around um i'll pick up on a few of them
though
uh i think some of them it's quite clear
uh we have been making
uh progress on since this since this
period so
in the second quarter hopefully we'll be
in in better shape
um and obviously there have been quite a
few targets that have been achieved so
well done for those councillors and
officers who've been working on those
targets that have been achieved
um there's one two i did want to pick up
though so um
eco 07
which was deliver three business
engagement events annually um
i think it refers in report there to the
fact that we could do those virtually
and i would like to try and see if we
can can get those moving forward as soon
as possible if
not um appreciate kobe has impacted and
businesses focuses have been different a
lot of businesses haven't been open over
this over the initial period of lockdown
so
it's understandable but i think we are
able to try and pick those up if they
haven't already been
um and then the same goes for some of
the
the parish engagement we do talk about
attending uh so many parish council
meetings
per year and supporting parishes with
various different things
i i think on that although i appreciate
the resources
intensive i think it's probably never
been easier to attend the parish council
meeting because so many are over zoomed
now or
or by virtual means so if we are able to
try and pick that back up
and try and push that forward i think
that would be very useful
um i won't go into it anymore i think
i think we're all aware of the uh the
targets that are sort of need a bit more
work or that have been delayed by
covington we did have the
performance target uh review
um a month or so ago so we did go
through some of these in quite quite
some detail at the time
and i'm confident that obviously we will
make further progress in the second
quarter given that obviously we've
returned more back to normal
uh since july than perhaps we didn't in
in the first quarter of the year
um any further comments or queries on
that paper anything you want to add cath
uh and then i'll bring carol uh cancer
ranking
uh no not really i think you made a
valid point obviously april to june is
the period that's been most affected by
covenant and that shows through the
targets with about a third of them being
affected by covid
i agree i think there will be more
progress to report at q2
and obviously we'll have the review of
the mini review would have taken place
by then so it'll be
a neater set of targets to discuss going
forward
yeah absolutely yeah the other thing to
add is obviously that several of the
economic development targets are under
review anyway because obviously
jill um jill is new as a as a new
director and caroline is a relatively
new
cabinet member on that so i think it's
important that we do review those as is
suggested by the paper um over to you
um council ready thank you council
i'm just going to say that we might want
to look at some of our targets anyway
um but just for the record um there
has been quite a lot of business
engagement actually one to one
throughout terms of support for um so if
we'd have
had that as a target you know we
smashed it so i think i know you can't
go back and put it in but that is
worth noting there was a lot of um
there's been a lot of one-to-one
and as councillors and uh members we've
all been speaking to businesses locally
and there's a few events that you know
i'm piggybacking on a tourism event
in a couple of weeks and speaking out
with one of our partners and
so we are we are doing this engagement
but um yeah in terms of
doing it under our banner um i
definitely think we could be doing more
and should be doing more and that will
be built in
brilliant thanksgiving i think that's a
valid point though actually
and maybe that's more about how we
record
um record uh some of the progress
against some of these targets because
you're absolutely right
in terms of the support the business
support that we've offered to
many businesses around the district
we've done a heck of a lot of business
engagement
it might not be an official event but
actually
perhaps we can find a way of recording
that into the system so that it's clear
that
um you know albeit that specific target
might not be met we are making
um very very clear progress towards it
um
councillor kenyon i'll bring you in next
yes thank you two questions one question
one statement
um which target review process were you
referring to when you said they've been
won a month ago
but my my comment really is some of the
targets and especially applies to
economic development but not everything
is is measurable
but it doesn't mean it's any less a
target to try to improve it
and it'll be a mistake to only have
measurable targets in there because they
do really
drive the attention of the officers to
achieve the targets that they're given
and if if there are things we want to
achieve for example like increasing uh
retention of graduates in the area if it
isn't a target
it will never get reviewed on a regular
basis and it will just get dropped
so just because a target isn't
necessarily measurable
in an objective way doesn't mean it
shouldn't be there
uh with a subjective attempt to
to gauge the progress because they're
really important things to achieve some
of them
absolutely i can't wholeheartedly agree
i think quite often we have
we have some very specific measurable
targets that are you know that are kind
of task and finish targets where once
you've done them you can mark them off
as complete and actually
um they're not always the the best
targets to improve performance on so
i would agree first question was that
the meeting i was referring to was the
quarterly performance management meeting
which i think
all cabinet members would get invited to
i can't remember
whether you weren't able to make it at
the time um
jeremy but uh we should all be getting
in the invites to those so if
if we're not can we just make sure that
they are coming out uh counselor can you
yes sir that's that wasn't uh a review
of what the
there's two kinds of reviews oh
sorry i misheard you maybe i thought you
were talking about the actual targets
as to what they are being reviewed
rather than progress on the existing
targets
no i think the the report refers to some
of the economic development
targets which are under review which is
which is a program
a process that carolyn and um and jill
are going through
um to review those but sorry the other
the other thing i meant was i think the
quarterly performance meeting just as an
aside
though i have asked that we um for the
next informal cabinet that we have this
and the recovery plans so both the the
council plan
uh the performance sort of targets that
sit with under it and
the recovery plans come back to uh a
next informal cabinet
i'm not sure whether we'll get through
all of them but i would like to just
review where we are with them and
consider whether we want to make any
changes at that stage
um you know or or revise any of the
the actions and targets within it so
we'll get that opportunity
uh in the next month or so any other
questions or
comments on that paper i think we're
being asked to note this one so i'm
happy to
move the recommendations do i have a
second
cancer powell thank you all those in
favor
brilliant thank you very much and then
we move to
[Music]
uh the area housing office consultation
so i'll
hand over to uh councillor powell
to lead us through on this one and
obviously uh councillor
cupid and i will uh be put in the
waiting room
i'll do that for you
right well um hello everyone um the area
housing consultation is something that
we discussed over the summer
um the background to this is that um
during the pandemic the area housing
offices were closed
um and there was no significant
uh problems that arose from that um
so it seemed to be a sensible way
forward to look at
whether we actually needed the poor area
housing officers that are left bearing
in mind some have closed in previous
years
and if you look at the savings
for foreclosure
they are very significant and would make
a
huge contribution to our resource
our financial resource and
the consultation was a very thorough one
involving all the people who
um actually use the uh the officers that
are left
um and a huge
and significant majority and said they
could use an
alternative method um amongst the
mitigation for it is that
in all cases in all areas there are at
least
three alternatives which people can use
and if people are in real difficulties
ritmold would make special arrangements
if that weren't necessary
and so um i'm happy to answer questions
before making the recommendations
so i can't see anybody's hand up so i
would make the recommendation and
the cabinet oh sorry caroline
carolyn no no sorry i i've lost you
on screen but i um thank you very good
report and uh
to agree with everything on that thank
you
in that case can i move the
recommendations then
the cabinet notes um the um
i'm just looking for it that kevin hopes
the feedback from the consultation
and that it ratifies the uh that
we will permanently close the
area housing offices all those in favor
oh just quickly on this
uh uh alan yeah mark i'm sorry to come
to
chair on that my apologies uh this uh is
has this already been published this
paper
not publicly it's not publicly uh where
it's where it speaks on uh
i only got to the end there as we were
speaking um
uh under human resources implications at
5.3.1
it says that the end and a redundancy
process would follow
um it's rhl yeah
um do we need any clarity on that
i mean that uh the i wouldn't like
anybody to be jumping at that and
making it look like uh we're making
people redundant if we're making post
redundant
um that's different so making post
redundant and redeploying people
or whatever other method you
you you look at uh keep still keeping
people on
um so that's a concern that that's there
for me anyway
uh that basically in any opposition
uh would pick that up uh so
is there anything we can do there at all
to
i know it's late uh but to but to put
some clarity between
uh whether it's the posts that are being
made it made redundant or the people
that have been made redundant
and the redundancy process would follow
even that we didn't
that we said that there were going to be
no compulsory redundancies
is that a valid point
alan uh where people's jobs are
concerned it's always a valid point
um but i am satisfied that the
litigation that wrinkles put in place
uh will not give us any problems
whatsoever
thank you councillor powell councillor
foster um
we we have had discussions with our
staff that
are part of this process because they
are all aware that the offices haven't
been reopened
so we've been reassuring staff along the
way and have had regular weekly meetings
with them
they are very clear that they will be
posts that are made redundant and that
we are looking at alternative
redeployment options for them
we've had at least nine members of our
customer services team
come forward and ask for their
redundancy figures because they would
choose to leave
and as a result of the increase in the
jobs that we would have in our contact
center because that's what we're
planning to do is to extend
the front line in the contact centre
there will be
a very there won't be any need for
compulsory redundancies at this stage
they will be voluntary
and we will be we're quite confident
that we'll be able to redeploy those
staff
where there are people that fall out of
this process
having said that we have made it clear
to our staff that because we are looking
at other areas of the business as well
and not least our planning function that
there may be
other redundancies that fall out of our
restructuring and that goes to our board
next week but we've
carefully worked with and communicated
with
all staff during this last few months
and we've had no
no negative feedback from them at all
we've also kept in touch with unions to
make sure that the union representatives
are aware
of the situation and we will be meeting
with them again next week with our staff
assuming the decision today is not to
reopen the offices
thank you yes ma'am
thanks for that lorraine uh that's
there's nothing i wouldn't expect anyway
i i know you would have uh
uh looked at it like that i'm just
wondering if if
if if i if i presented this uh a cabinet
at council i'd expect that to be one of
the first questions
and i would expect anyone questioning
this
to mix up uh the post-ridden say and
people be made redundant that's what i
would do if i was attacking this
paper uh so if the other side were
minded too that's what i'd expect that's
all i wondered if we could put anything
in there if you're happy as it is then i
am too
oh we have a recommendation which i'm i
have moved is
thank you councilor parking all in favor
thank you that's carried nikki could you
ask alex to return the charlotte please
they're both returning to the meeting
room now
thank you for that just for your
information share the recommendations
were accepted by the cabinet
okay brilliant thank you for that um
just while i remember there was a query
that i had from uh councillor potts on
that paper in relation to the
costs of the lease of the killer marsh
building
um would would uh
would it be you jill would you mind just
contacting councillor no
uh actually well i think might not be a
good time at the moment because i know
her mum's in hospital
but i think we need to contact someone
from killer march at some stage just to
just clarify that point because i think
there was no
uh mention of cost uh of the cost of the
lease there obviously it's
her own building i think so um
there was an issue there anyway if you
could if you could look into that at
some stage and speak to them about it
that'd be great
thank you thanks john um okay so we move
on to
item eight which is the temporary
amendments to the statement of community
involvement to enable
public consultation on the local plan
during the coronavirus pandemic
which is over to you charlotte
thank you chair um this is uh hopefully
quite a short report
it's uh just to be really sort of
crystal clear it is not sort of
launching into any
uh next consultation on the local plan
that will be the subject of a future
cabinet report and will be
um publicized and sort of fully
advertised to residents
so this is solely to amend the way in
which we carry out consultations
um as we've said previous in previous
press releases for
um obvious reasons we um suspended
the next or progress to the next
consultation of the local plan
due to kovid 19 in march through to june
i don't think that was the right
decision uh and was fully supported by
the inspector
um but this is now to look ahead you
know sort of
uh any further covert issues uh allowing
to when we proceed to the next
consultation just be able to
sort of fully involve all residents as
we promise to do
so the main two amendments proposed here
are
in terms of usually draft plans or the
consultation documents would be
available at the council
building and at libraries etc which i
know
aren't all open at the moment so the
mitigation proposal
we're proposing there is to do that via
obviously website and documents
but also to anybody who needs it to post
it out
in full and likewise if anybody is
shielding
uh or you know for any other reason is
unable to get access to the documents
we will also uh post all documentation
out
and make every effort to you know make
sure everything's available to all
residents
and to be able to comment um i think
it's all included outlined in the
recommendations
just as a further point um i know that
individual counsellors and ward members
will also
be making representations and keeping
residents fully
aware of what's happening and offering
guidance to
residents on the next consultation when
that comes
and we don't have a date for that yet
just to be really clear on that
um so pending any questions can i
move the recommendations in section six
six point one and six point two
okay i'm happy to second the
recommendations are there any
questions or comments from anyone
no okay uh i'll move to the vote then
all those in favor
okay thank you that's carried and then
we moved to
the planning enforcement plan
uh so back to you um council cupid
um thanks again jeff um so
this is one of the documents that was
outlined in the
um council plan and in the council plan
targets which you were discussing
earlier in your report
and this was originally due to come to
cabinet and then planning committee
in april but again due to covid was
delayed so
we're now picking that up um i think we
know
as an administration and as a council
enforcement and particularly planning
enforcement is a really important
priority for us in a key aim so this is
the start of
of that process to really put that at
the headline
and sort of advertise to residents so
this is a draft
enforcement plan which sets out
what we can and can't do on enforcement
it sets out clear targets for responding
to residents
and keeping them updated and it also
sets out for the first time
a way of monitoring performance by the
planning committee
and by a councillors so that we know
what's happening with enforcement cases
um because i know in the past even
myself as a ward member you
report things and you're not always
quite sure what's happened or what
action has been taken
um so this this is a very draft uh
report but i wanted to bring it to
cabinet at this stage
um it is also with the comms team uh
prior
to sort of flash it up into a resident
friendly version
and add some infographics etc for a sort
of formal
launch of it um so it's for to ask
cabinet as part of this to approve this
in principle
as a sort of starting point um to then
comes it up so to speak and finalize
that and then it will go to
planning committee to be formally
adopted
hopefully this month or maybe next month
if it's not quite ready
so yeah any questions
okay again i'm happy to second that one
are there any
uh any questions on that
no okay yeah completely agree i think if
we can make it
uh more uh customer friendly in terms of
how it's presented i think that'll be
very good
um so you know to definitely support
that to that recommendation
okay we'll move to the vote uh all those
in favor
okay that's kerry thank you very much
and then
get back to my agenda uh we moved to
i believe we moved to urgent items uh
there are no urgent items that i wish to
raise
and then we moved to the exclusion of
the press and public so if you're
joining us from the live stream or
watching back
from youtube thank you very much i hope
you found it useful and interesting
and and uh goodbye so thank you very
much i'll just
move the item uh that the public be
excluded from the meeting
during the discussion of the following
items of business to avoid the
disclosure
to them of the exempt information as
defined in part one of schedule 12a
to the local government act at 1972
so thank you very much if we can end the
live feed
you